Fah Fah foo he's getting older and
yesterday well you know there's always a
camera on him yesterday I didn't want to
bring this up but yesterday he fell
asleep during the show at nine o'clock
when he's supposed to be working
oh really I really do think that yeah
and I mean it's kind of disturbing to me
I need him awake during the show and now
he's sleeping during the show and you
know what happened to him
he ate like every black-and-white
cooking on Wednesday we have cupcake
Wednesday so crumbs you can smell the
sugar well he ate every black-and-white
cookie and you see else got him nothing
he ate every single one like that's just
discussion up a dozen yeah I mean
they're beautiful cookies you want to
have one I get it dude cop to it you
fall asleep during the show I did I did
fall asleep but I was expire I was no no
I was tired and I definitely closed my
eyes I want to see the tape I know I was
never out okay dude you were snoring and
licking your chops first of all you
can't tell our story because there's no
sound on now look tell me are you asleep
I'm not asleep
Robin look that's a video deny you're
sleeping there um I don't I didn't think
I was but it looks like I am yeah
at one point while he's sleeping he's
licking his teeth and gums you know what
I love though he still got the pen
behind his ear while he's asleep Kait
some business but this is disrespectful
to me anyone know it is late I mean come
on it's wrong what's your energy okay
I've never I haven't done that ever so
you say no no really I haven't done that
well Howard obviously the the [ __ ] TV
Nazis are back there they would have
caught me what is that move you do with
your tongue and you I don't know rewind
the tape a little bit what are you
waiting down there I think a fly landed
on Gary's lip you know I'll admit what
I'm sleeping in my office after the show
I take a snooze
but during the show we got to stay awake
that's a prerequisite for working here
really absolutely bed too late I do
they're coming what time you go to sleep
last night 11 yeah and you sleep in here
and doing work so go to bed at 10:00 I
don't sleep in here during work that was
really one incident ma'am which by the
way I have to tell you I'm gonna point
out right now black and white cookies DG
I probably had like seven or eight but
they're small ones that the big giant
ones okay but Gary you just lost a bunch
of weight I got it under control
I do have to diet Robin he had seven
black and white cookies myself on
Wednesday boy oh boy he goes right out
like a baby
yeah not a worry in the world I'm not
worried boy awful seeing me sleeping
around here anything goes I'm the
producer
yeah I'm gonna produce right now
he was thinking about the show anyways
you dream
is there a way I can make the job more
exciting for you so you can stay awake
during missions you know it's not about
the excitement LEM right all right well
go back in your office and try and stay
awake